so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Valiant Comics and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of this
video you'll have a strong understanding
of how they started as well as how the
company has changed over the years
leading up to the current day so
understanding the history of Valiant
Comics requires that we delve into some
of the history regarding Marvel Comics
where some may believe that Marvel
Entertainment existed as a sone company
it was acquired by Disney in 2009 and
truth Marvel was originally a subsidiary
of magazine management company which was
owned by Martin Goodman because magazine
management was losing money due to the
decrease in popularity of men's
magazines and the increased popularity
of comics despite the early success of
Marvel's publications in 1968 another
company called perfect film and Chemical
Corporation which was owned by a man
named Martin Ackerman bought out
Goodman's company for Marvel became a
standout publication under P F and C
with the introduction of spider-man the
Fantastic Four and the Avengers because
of financial issues unaccounted for by
public documents in 1969 perfect film
and chemical reported a profit loss of
35 million dollars leading to a name
change in 1973 under CEO Sheldon
Feinberg with the new company titled
cadence industries while financial
problems continued with Marvel Comics
helping to keep the company afloat to a
degree the consistent profit losses led
to complete bankruptcy and liquidation
in 1986 because Marvel was one of the
subsidiaries of cadence industries
during the liquidation sales former
editor-in-chief Jim shooter attempted to
purchase the company but were outbid by
media mogul Ronald Perelman and new
world pictures as a result Jim shooter
along with several others acquired
financing from venture capitalist firm
triumph Capital a company that lends
money to fledgling businesses while
maintaining a controlling stake with an
expectation of financial returns once
they're off the ground using the money
provided shooter established Voyager
communications as a parent company that
focused on creating cover ebook
counterparts to Nintendo and
professional wrestling games and
concepts using the fledgling popularity
as a platform in 1991 Valiant Comics was
introduced as a working imprint of
Voyager and after reaching out to
existing publishers like gold key comics
an imprint of Western publishing valiant
attained licenses necessary to write and
release the publication's of Magnus
robot fighter
and solar men of the atom because the
titles were so well received
valiant began working on original
creations to establish valium comics as
a legitimate competitor to both Marvel
and DC to this end between 1991 and 1992
valiant created and released stories
revolving around EXO Man O'War Rai
Shadow Man
Harbinger Arjun Armstrong as well as
eternal warrior using this as a
jumping-off platform and because each of
these characters existed in their own
comics and August and September of 1992
valiant launched a line wide unity
storyline as a way to begin crossing
their various characters over and in
effort to provide a more cohesive
universe this combined with the
groundbreaking concept of zero issues
which served to introduce origins for
their characters meant that the
popularity of valiant titles were
boosted across the board with comics
like Solar Man of the atom selling 360
thousand issues post unity rather than
60-thousand issues before unity as a
result in 1992 valiant was named new
publisher of the year in 1993 it was
named publisher of the year over both
Marvel and DC and the monthly price
guides such as wizard magazine
Overstreet and others recorded volumes
accolades which in turn drove the prices
of the valiant comics even higher with
some of the original pre unity comics
selling for $100 or more due to the fact
that so few were originally printed
looking to capitalize on the popularity
of Voyager communications and the
valiant line of comics triumph Capitol
sold Voyager communications along with
all of its subsidiaries to acclaim
entertainment for 65 million dollars the
reason for this purchase was at acclaim
plan to further their sales by crossing
the valiant line over with their video
games and other entertainment media
however shortly after their acquisition
comics sales came to a screeching halt
due to the comic bust of the 1990s what
I mean here is that tracking the value
of comic books on a national scale
didn't happen until 1976 under the
Overstreet price guide which served to
analyze and provide a monetary value for
all of comics both past and present and
so by the early 1980s collectors have
become aware that rare or important
comic books could be worth a large sum
of money due to the fact that so few of
them had remained in good quality after
they released to the public what this
meant was at stories like 1975's
giant-size x-men number one and 1985
crisis on Infinite Earths we
worth a lot of money if they were in
good condition while classic stories
like 1956 is DC showcase number four and
1962 s amazing fantasy number 15 were
worth even more money with the most
pristine copies valued near 1 million
dollars following this revelation
speculators looking to purchase the next
comic that would hopefully be worth a
fortune
artificially inflated the comic book
market by collecting multiple copies of
comics that were deemed extremely
popular among readers or had huge impact
on popular characters and so by 1994
following the death of Superman and the
Batman nightfall story arcs collectors
had purchased the stories in droves
looking to the value they would hold in
the future however the opposite effect
happened and that Marvel and DC as well
as value due to their post unity
popularity began producing massive
amounts of comics and in turn their
value plummeted due to an oversaturation
of the market as a result by late 1995
pre-orders for comics were reaching the
lowest point of the decade and the
titles of Valiant Comics under acclaim
were no exception realizing the
situation they were in and that action
needed to be taken to revitalize
interest in their titles in late 1996
acclaim relaunched the dying comics line
as acclaimed comics valiant heroes while
the names of the titles belonging to XO
Man O'War bloodshot and Shadow Man were
the same the stories were the acclaimed
valiant lineup were launched as a new
universe which was more easily adapted
to video games furthermore in 2000
acclaimed launched a second unity saga
as a six-part story arc to unify the pre
and post acclaim valiant universes by
eliminating the least popular titles and
keeping the most popular ones
however acclaim stopped producing the
series after only half the books were
released due in part to a public payment
problem with the artists and severe
losses from recently released for its
video games what I mean here is that
during the late 1990s acclaim was the
sole provider of video games based on
the World Wrestling Federation
but because the WWF was competing with
WCW during the Monday Night Wars the
contest for rating supremacy extended to
merchandise as well with WCW under the
banner a video game developer and
publisher THQ
and experiencing record profits due to
the high quality of their games in late
1999 the WWF severed its contract with
acclaim and allied itself with THQ this
combined with a series of bad business
decisions like failing to pay royalties
to mary-kate and Ashley
Olson for games developed and sold by
acclaim in addition to the attempt of
boosting the popularity of games like
BMX xxx by including nudity all led to
acclaim entertainment filing for chapter
7 bankruptcy resulting in an auction of
his assets during which time the rights
to Magnus robot fighter and solar man of
the atom were returned to Western
publishing who still maintain the rights
to those characters now by the following
year in 2005 Dinesh Shan Dasani and
Jason Kothari two students from the
University of Southern California and
Pennsylvania's Wharton School of
Business were able to acquire the rights
Italian comics and all of their titles
during the auction sale of acclaim
entertainment with Sean Dasani stepping
into the role of chief creative officer
in Kothari becoming the CEO Diane comics
was rebranded to valiant entertainment
and over the course of the next seven
years the two began reaching out to
veterans of the comic and entertainment
industry by bringing in individuals like
Peter Cuneo the former Marvel CEO who
bought the company out of bankruptcy
following the speculator bus of the
1990s in addition to Warren Simmons the
former writer of Marvel Comics among
others furthermore in an effort to
ensure that readers had a new place to
start without any concern about the
titles tying in to past events valiant
relaunched their lineup in two phases
the first phase came in 2012 during an
event titled the summer of valiant which
took place between May and August and
saw the titles of XO Man O'War Harbinger
bloodshot and Archer and Armstrong all
launched consecutively under Robert
Vendetti Joshua disorde Dwayne's
Rosinski
and Fred van Lent respectively with a
plan to year arc for each character that
would run until their completion in 2014
receiving critical acclaim for these
stories in the fact that they
concentrated heavily on character
development by focusing on the title
characters directly by the end of 2012
valiant had received four best publisher
of 2012 awards from any Cool News comic
impact mania and mind of Scott as well
as a series of other awards including
best super team of 2012 for Harbinger
and best ongoing series for XO Man O'War
following up on the successful relaunch
and the popularity that came with it and
2013 valiant initiated phase two of
their launch with the return of quantum
and woody and eternal warrior as well as
unity which serves as a value an
equivalent of The Avengers or the
Justice League furthermore with a
two-year story arcs of Harbinger
bloodshot and Archer and Armstrong
coming to the
and valiant continued the slow rollout
of their stories by launching new
ongoing series in the form of ninja
Imperium ivar time Walker and bloodshot
reborn as well as introducing a
four-issue miniseries titled the valiant
in 2015 which crossed over their most
popular titles leading into a new book
of death miniseries including the fall
of bloodshot the fall of ninja the fall
of Harbinger and the fall of XO Man
O'War with that being said we're going
to bring this video to an end and I will
catch you guys later peace